What do you think about Sarah
Lynn?
Oh, I don't really
think about her all that much.
I mean, obviously,
I'm a fan of her early work
which both satirized
and celebrated
youth culture's obsession
with sex,
but I do wonder
as a third-wave feminist
if it's even possible for women
to reclaim their sexuality
in this deeply entrenched
patriarchal society,
or if claiming to do so
is just a lie we tell ourselves
so we can more comfortably cater
to the male gaze.
-Uh, what?
-But you know,
on the other hand,
I worry that conversations
like this one
often dismiss her as a mere
puppet of the industry...
-That's my same worry.
-...incapable of engaging
-in these discussions herself...
-Obviously.
...and infantilization,
which is itself a product
-of the deeply misogynistic
society we live in.
-So deep.
But like I said,
I don't really think about her
all that much.
Okay, but I was more asking,
like, what do you think
about her living here?
Oh, right.
Well, what was your relationship
like with her
when you were working
on the show?
It was very good,
very professional.
(CLEARS THROAT) BoJack,
where did you go to college?
Honey, college
is for ugly people
who can't tap dance.
-I want to be an architect.
-(LAUGHING) Sweetheart,
Mommy didn't do what Mommy did
to that Star Search producer
so that you could be
an architect.
-Aw.
-All right, take it sleazy,
everybody.
Wait, BoJack, um,
what are you doing this weekend?
I don't know.
I'll probably just go
to the amusement park,
maybe the circus,
fly a kite on the beach,
watch the sunset,
then I'll head back to my place
to watch any number
of Disney princess movies
while eating ice cream
straight from the tub.
-Whoa, can I come?
-(LAUGHS) Yeah,
like I want to spend my weekend
hanging out with a little girl.
(LAUGHS) Good one!
You should write
for the Shouts and Murmurs.
See you Monday!
So the makeup
they were putting on you
was not for the show,
-it was just for the weekend?
-Why does that matter?
I'm just trying
to understand the story.
Do you think it's possible
that you inviting Sarah Lynn
into your house now is your way
of compensating for not--
No, Diane,
I'm just helping out a friend.
I'm not trying to play out
some weird, sick dad fantasy,
or resolve a deep guilt
for past neglect,
or even try to retroactively fix
my own childhood
by recreating someone else's,
and I'm especially not doing
all those things at once!
Okay.
What happened?
Did somebody hurt
my precious baby?